hello everyone and welcome back to the
2021 candidates tournament it's fabiano
caruana versus dean leeron uh so fabi is
trying to get back at the dink for
defeating him
in the first half of the tournament this
is the only victory that being achieved
so far which is pretty incredible now
there were extremely high hopes for ding
as he was on his amazing uh
100 games unbeaten streak 110 games i
believe unbeaten streak
and after that you know just qualifying
for the candidates and everything
everyone thought that he would be uh you
know maybe not
winning the candidates but that he will
be pushing up until the very end
uh but you know uh it's not exactly what
happened
uh but like i said uh fabiano is the
only player he's defeated so far and now
fabi has the white pieces and he would
very much like to retaliate
and maybe catch up to the nepo and
and the others so uh let's see let's see
how this game went it's quite a crazy
one but
there were a lot of crazy games um in
this round one game in particular that
we are also going to cover so don't
worry i know you guys are probably
thinking uh you know uh
let's show that game but we're gonna
show all the games so uh no worries uh
but uh that being said let's uh check
out what happened here fabi with the
white pieces opens with e4
we have e5 by d knight to f3 knight to
c6 and the bishop to b5 so
all right just a normal royal opus here
uh we have a6 morphy's defense and now
bishop to a4 we have knight to f6 and we
have
castles now so bishop to e7
uh rook to e1 and now b5 pushing back
that bishop bishop to b3 and here
being just castles and now well you
could go for something like c3 and allow
black to go maybe for um for a nice
martial attack and
probably if uh fobby plays c3 ding
definitely goes for the martial attack
there's no
question about that but uh fabi goes for
a4 which is something that's considered
to be uh sort of the anti-martial
approach uh to avoid such a dangerous
line so here a4 we have b4 by ding
and now a5 grabbing more space on the
queen side and now
d6 and here uh fabi had uh fabi already
had this position he had it in
norway chess in 2020 against uh
aryanthari
and he continued with c3 in that game
but here he plays d3 and he still waits
at
uh to throw in a few moves before he
goes to c3 and maybe
uh with the eventual d4 so here bishop
the e6 attacking fab is bishop on b3
and fabi just trades here we have
captures captures and only now
c3 preparing to strike in the center
with the d4
uh ding goes rook to b8 now even if he
captures then he's gonna have a nice uh
uh open or semi-open b file uh and here
knight
beat d2 uh interestingly the position
has been reached in 2020
uh in the game between even charity and
alexander uh
don chenko that shot each one very
nicely he strike
uh he struck in the center with d4 right
away but here
uh fabi uh still preparing at knight b
to d2
and now comes rook to b5 knight to d7
also
uh unknown move here uh we have rook to
b5 biting
and now finally d4 attacking in the
center yes your a5 pawn is under attack
but fabi says
we are not going to defend this pawn so
d4
uh we have b captures on c3 b captures
and now
e captures on d4 we have c capture
sunday four five we now has this very
nice uh center here
uh and um uh
ding already had this position uh it's
very interesting he had it
three times and something most likely
fabi used in his preparation for this
game
uh ding had it against the grishop he
had a against basa mamin and he had
against the darius schwirtz
and all of the three games were drawn
but in all of those three games
ding played knight to b4 and here ding
probably thought okay
since i already had this position three
times i'm playing it against karwana and
the candidates
obvious obviously fabi prepared for
knight to b4 so i'm gonna play queen to
c8
and the queen to c8 is a new move here
so here
black announces that he is now ready to
capture on a5
and that he wants to push this pawn to
c5 create a past c pawn
and then just start pushing so uh it is
uh now already as of move 16 that we
have a completely new game and
fabi now needs to show us what he's
prepared for this so he goes uh
bishop to a3 uh with uh
well just preparing e5 basically and
giving up the a5 pawn so dean grabs it
with knight captures on a5
and now queen to c2 and now it's uh well
okay the c5 uh square is defended many
times
but the ding still strikes in the center
with c5 doesn't matter as it's also
defended
many times so he would very much enjoy
creating a pass pawn here
but this is what fabi prepared he goes
e5 now so the knight is under attack you
have to react to this
d captures on e5 and now uh d captures
on c5 and now
after all is said and done uh yes uh
black does have a past a pawn
but white already has a past c pawn
that's on c5
currently and if that pawn can start
marching up the board could be very good
and uh black is up upon but it's a it's
a doubled e pawn so
there shouldn't be too much too much of
a trouble uh you know containing that so
here
knight back to c6 and now comes
knight to e4 fabi doesn't bother
grabbing back the pawn here
because it's not very not very um
well promising uh for example after
captures captures and captures you might
see knight g4
attacking the rook and also the f2 pawn
and then
something like rook to e2 uh bishop
captures on c5 this is all pretty much
forced the bishop captures queen
captures
and now you get this position where
there's a lot of pressure coming from
black it's not really white that it's
pushing for anything
and if this pawn starts marching down
the board uh you're gonna have a very
hard time defending this so instead of
just grabbing back the pawn fabi goes
knight to e4
and now dink captures we have knight
captures on e4
rook captures on e4 and now while you
could
try and get a defender over to e5 i
think fabi uh
ding knew that fabi was not really
interested in winning back material
so he just goes rook to d8 getting the
rook to the nice open d file
uh and now rook ate the e1 by fabi
and now while there is nothing more
pretty pretty much to improve he does
defend it with bishop to f6 and now fabi
still needs to prove that
uh this position uh was it worth the
pawn and how how is he intending to
start pushing this blockaded pawn
so here we have h4 by fabi trying to uh
most likely create some further
weaknesses on the king side
and h6 by ding i know some of you are
always joking i say ding side but i
always say king side
uh and here rook fourth to e3 bringing
back the rook probably with the idea of
maybe
somehow shifting the knight over maybe
to a better square maybe to e4 and then
maybe the
d6 if at all possible but we have rook
to d5
and here adding shows that he is now
ready to go after the c5 pawn the bishop
is also coming to e7
to help out with the attack and this
pawn i think is now very very certain
that will not
uh you know stay there for very long so
here fabi needs to do something he needs
an active idea and he starts with the g4
he wants to bust open the position with
g5 so first the queen to e8 by ding
and now comes king to g2 improving the
safety of the king a little bit also if
needed you can maybe shift the rook over
to h1
but now h5 now if if pawn captures
you're ready to recapture with the queen
so of course g5 by fabi and only now
ding brings the bishop back to e7 being
wanted to bring the bishop back to a7 so
yeah g5 only only helps him really uh
and now
this pawn will fall there's not much fun
we can do about this so now it's time to
reclaim at least
a little bit of material knight captures
on e5 bishop captures on c5 with bishop
captures on c5 and now rook
b captures in c5 attacking the queen
here
and here it's again a tough position for
fabi his queen is under attack and also
there's now a triple attack on the
knight here
so there aren't really all that many
moves you can play here yes uh the
position looks promising for white but
if you know black doesn't give you a
moment to you know recollect your forces
you're not really going to achieve all
that much so here
queen to g6 the strongest move by far uh
if you don't want to you know lose any
unnecessary material
uh offers a queen trade now of course
you cannot go uh any
uh knight grabbing because the queen is
undefended on e8
so here being trades we have captures
captures and now comes e5 and now this
pawn is defended
and also this is a pass pawn so ding now
has two pass pawns and
fabi still needs to show what what he
can do
but luckily he calculated everything
precisely and pushes
f4 and this is now a very nice pawn push
uh point being that if the pawn is
captured you just easily win
for example rookie to check and if king
of seven knight h8 is checkmate the the
phone covers
f6 and there's nowhere for for the black
king to go to knight covers g6
so only one of the ideas so f4 cannot be
captured and even though
uh 5 is down upon this f4 push does give
him
a considerable counter play so here we
have rook to d2 with
check and now unfortunately for for fob
you have to block this you can't really
move the king for example if something
like king h3 then rook
c2 and then you could run into a lot of
trouble knight is coming to d4
and so on so instead after rook to d to
check we have uh
rook three blocking on e2 and now
uh ding just uh trades and alleviates
some of the pressure along the e file so
rook captures on e2 rook captures and
now knight to d4 you could also capture
on e4 here but then maybe just knife
captures on f4
and you know and not much is happening
here so
knight to d4 uh ding still trying
something
now attacks the rook and we have rook to
e4 so what do you play here uh you could
also consider something like rook
captures an e5
but then we get rook captures knight
captures and a5
you don't really want to fight against
this past pawn it's uh
it's this will be a winning end game for
black so instead after knight to d4 we
have rook to e4
uh and now comes rook to c2 with check
we have
king to f1 by fabi and now rook to c1
with check
king f2 we rook the c2 with check king
f1 rook to c1 with
check and now king to f2 and here ding
played rook to c2 with
check and it was in this position on
move 40
that the players agreed to a draw they
were both very long time i think ding
was on some two minutes on the clock
fobby had some four minutes on the clock
but
now that they've reached time control uh
they agreed that there's nothing more
to push for here uh if anything only
black can push here so
not much point in continuing if fabi
tries something like
you know bringing the king closer uh he
might run into something like knight f3
check then the pawn is under attack if
king d1 just
rook here attacks the king king c1 let's
say rook d6 attacks the defender of the
pawn here
and now we'd probably have to trade
captures captures and again it's
black who has the outside pass pawn if
anyone's pushing here it's black
and on the other hand if you don't go to
e1 let's say you try king e3
it's not much better rook c3 check you
can very easily you know harass
uh rook uh to see to check and now if
king to d3
uh we could go rook to c5 and uh again
there's not much
really uh to do here you could go knight
captures on e5 knight to f5 now going
after the spawn and knight to f3
defending
now we would have this position where
the material is equal black still with
the outside past pawn
it's uh hard to imagine that anyone
could achieve anything here
so after rook the sea to check they
agreed to a draw and
fabi uh misses his opportunity to get uh
to get back
at the ding for beating him in the first
half of the tournament and also trying
to catch up
uh to the leader uh or leaders uh as we
are
not okay i disclosed in the previous
video so we all know uh that
nipple is leading the tournament but i
will not show the standings uh because i
will show at least one more game from
round 10
uh so stay tuned for that uh so
that's the game i hope you guys enjoyed
it uh fabi tried to pull something off
but i really didn't uh
see where where the poison was being
really
you know really played it perfectly he
didn't want to
hang on to material but fabi wasn't
interested in recollecting the material
so it kind of worked
well for both of them but yeah i hope
you guys enjoyed that
i would like to thank philippe compow um
mario and sinosa israel stones david
kimura and
vasudevan srinivasan for contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day